hello everyone and welcome back to the
park champs championship
this is the final match and this is the
final game uh so this is game three
uh the tiebreaker as boy boy lost in
game one he had uh he had a good game
but
then uh in a very difficult position he
blundered his queen and the hutch won
game one
uh but then voyboy quickly retaliated uh
in game two
i think it was a like a really really
short game maybe some 16 moves he
he won a piece and then hutch just
resigned uh and now this is game three
uh so
uh real really an intense game so i do
hope you enjoyed it uh
and they are well very close rating wise
i think voibor is almost 1600 and
uh hutch is almost 1500 i believe
uh but that's uh as this this is only
rapid so
they might be uh rated differently in
blitz and so on
so uh without further ado let's check it
out uh and yeah also i would just like
to congratulate everyone who played the
arena yesterday
uh here we will just announce the
winners of the arena
there you have it uh for the meadow
arena la vie meadow won the tournament
uh followed by unrated boss and buuve
king
and the top 10 are chess hater louis
soletti
uh college 3k uh buzomati shiva manipato
bet player is playing in chess world one
six one two so congratulations guys
on uh playing and winning uh and also
the winners of the agar matra friday
arena are feeding master blank 37
uh in first place second place is physic
is good uh and
third place uh josiah uh next we have
yupo six one ten uh yonash mb
feeder master super gm one uh
uh column two thousand and seven are two
twenty three and see that
akm29 so congratulations guys and also
for those of you who might have missed
it
uh in the stream i was joined by tamar
rajaba who also helped me commentate on
some of the games and we also had a lot
of fun
so do check it out if you missed it and
also uh do check out rajabov's
channel he also created a youtube
channel and where he is currently
analyzing some of his own games so
do check it out it will be the first
link you see in the description below
now getting back to the game boy with
the white pieces opens with e4 and hutch
goes for c5 he goes for the sicilian
defense
knight to f3 we have knight to c6 and
now d4
just striking in the center we have
captures captures uh and now e6 hatch
goes for the time of variation of the
sicilian
uh we have knight to c3 and bishop the
c5 now
queen to c7 is the main move here bishop
to c5 is somewhat rarer but also also
played
so knight d to b5 going for knight to d6
check and the hatch even uh
makes it happen so knight checks bishop
captures and queen characters and now
the queen is
uh somewhat uh preventing uh the black
from successfully developing but you
could go for something like queen to e7
maybe try and force a queen trade uh
like this however hatch is not in a
hurry he goes knight
g to e7 and now bishop to d3 voyboy just
continues development we have castles by
both sides
castles castles uh and now there is one
game in the database where knight the g6
was played
but here we have b5 by hutch and it is
as of move 10 that we have a completely
new game hachna wants to play bishop b7
get the rook to c8
maybe queen to c7 uh kick away the white
queen from there and hopefully
get some d5 in so here voiber goes back
immediately with queen to g3
now with the idea that uh maybe he can
go some like bishop to h6 maybe create
some
uh checkmating chances against the black
king so hatch
plays knight to g6 uh not allowing this
and also
uh if e5 is played you also block the
the light square bishop so rook to e1
also f4
f5 could be an idea here for voyboy uh
or maybe just
for a moment you don't have h4 since the
queen and the knight are covering that
but f4 f5
might be an idea so here instead rook
the e1
boy uh keeps it keeps it calm not
rushing uh with anything as he did
blunder his queen in game one he doesn't
want to do anything rash
we have knight seat e5 now putting
pressure on the bishop here and voyboy
now develops
with a double attack here now while you
could capture here on f4
uh hutch decides to go back so just
knight to c6
and voyboy now goes e5 he opens up his
light square bishop
uh and he kind of he kind of prevents d6
or d5 since uh
you could just capture here and the
queen and the bishop are nicely
supporting that
pawn on d6 so here hutch decides to
remove the bishop from f4 we have knight
captures
queen captures and now comes at the
moment where
the magic happens uh or where the magic
should have happened uh hutch plays
knight to the e7 he now wants to shift
the other side
the other knight over to the king side
with knight to g6 to again block a
voyboy's light square bishop however
this this is a terrible blunder that
loses the game on the spot so
feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for a voy boy while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
spotting the double attack and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's queen to e4 now uh this is uh just
terrible for black there's the checkmate
threat and also the rook on a8 is
hanging and
there is no defense you have to defend
checkmate and then you just gobble
up a full rook however voyboy missed
this he went for rook to e3 he just
wants to get another rook into the
attack
and just go after the black king and now
knight to g6 now
this idea is no longer possible since
the knight now blocks uh
your access to the h7 pawn the queen is
under attack so logo goes back queen g3
and now finally queen to c7 uh hutch
develops the queen will
bring the bishop to b7 and so on we have
rook 8 to e1
voyboy now doubles up on the e file adds
another uh
uh protector to the e5 pawn and now
finally bishop to b7
and now while you could consider
something like h4 h5 since the queen no
longer guards
the h4 square that void but first get
rid of gets rid of black's
strong light square bishop with bishop
to e4 uh
hatch continues development rook a to c8
and the boy boy trades now we have
bishop captures queen captures and now
rook to f3 getting another knight into
the game sorry the rook uh entered
into the attack and now rook the c5
hutch goes
after the e5 pawn you could go for some
like b4 kick away the knight and then
just pick up the c2 pawn
however hutch wants to go after the e5
pawn instead with queen to c7 to add a
third attacker to the pawn
and now voy boy finally tries to
dislodge the knight with h4
and now while you could uh play h5 to
stop the pawn
from reaching h5 hatch just continues
his attack against
the e5 pawn so queen the east queen to
c7 going after the e5 pawn
and now voila has to defend it as this
pawn is really preventing black from
further developing
with the d6 or d5 so look back to e3
now again the pawn is defended three
times and now uh
knight back to e7 here hutch is
threatening knight to f5 to go after the
queen and the rook
and voyboy now uh doesn't uh react to
this
rather he continues with h5 he wants to
play h6 and check made the black king
but now hatch goes for it knight to f5
and now there's a nice fork here
uh voyboy moves the queen and hutch
picks up the rook so he wins the
exchange knight captures we have queen
captures
and now uh voyboy is down the exchange
however he's still hoping for queen g5
h6 let's say queen to g7 checkmate but
hatch prevents this by playing h6 uh
preventing queen to g3 and this pawn can
no longer reach
h6 so here uh we've looked at d1
now again uh keeping an eye on this
square not allowing any d5 ideas
uh and now rook to c8 again you could go
for b4 and rook captures but hatch
prefers to prepare this and also
hutch knows that voyboy is preparing
rook d4 to g4 and he also wants to block
it with rook to c4 and this is what
voyboy goes for rook to d4
uh we rook to c4 and now uh voip trades
here
uh rook captures on c4 we have queen
captures on c4
and now queen to a7 going uh for a
double attack here attacking both of the
pawns but hatch defends them with queen
to c6
we have queen back to e3 by boy boy and
now d6 finally getting this freeing move
in
and now uh you don't really have much
options we have captures captures
and now g3 making some reading room for
the king planning king the g2 to
get the king to maybe a little bit of a
safer square
so rook to c4 a very nice active square
for the rook grabbing hold of the fourth
rank and voivo goes king to g2
we have queen to c7 now finally
preparing this b4 idea to pick up the c2
pawn
and now a3 preventing b4 but a5 there is
no way to stop b4
so king back to f1 and now finally hachi
goes for it b4
we have a captures a captures and now
knight to the e4
but now just rook captures on c2 here
voivo goes queen to b3 to defend his uh
b2 pawn
and also attack the rook however hutch
just says okay i'm up the exchange
there's no point in
dragging this on i'm just going to trade
queen's queen to c4 with
check captures and captures and here
uh you are now up the exchange and it's
very very likely that you will also win
the b2 pawn so here voibo goes knight to
the d2 but it just
rooked to c2 now with a double attack
here
king e2 avoidable defends the knight but
now rook captures on b2
we have king to d3 robonaut wants to
somehow get
rid of this pawn and f6 now now
preparing e5 and also preparing to bring
the king into the game which is
definitely the way to go uh when you're
in an end game so f3 uh voyboy now wants
to move his knight and
he doesn't want to lose the f2 pawn but
now king f7 uh we have
knights to e4 and now uh goes for
rook to b3 check you could also maybe
try and keep on uh
hang on to this pawn but he prefers to
give up this pawn and go
after the king side pawns so king c4 and
now he gobbles up on f3
rook captures and now volvo captures on
b4
we rook the e3 getting rid of the
defender of the g3 pawn
very well played by hutch and now knight
the d6 check we have king e7
knight the c8 checked by voyboy king d7
and now knight to b6 with
check we have king to c6 and now as
there are no more checks
knight to c4 but now rook to e4
here you could go for the pawn here uh
but hatch now shows that he
is a great student of the end game and
he just plays
rook to e4 he knows that if he captures
the knight
then the pawn and the king and opponent
game is winning for black as you are up
two pawns and
voyboy is uh without uh without a move
here so king c3
we have rook captures on c4 king
captures on c4 and now just
e5 and this is now of course a winning
end game for black
however however uh they are both
extremely low on time and when i say
extremely low i mean voila has some 30
seconds on the clock and hutch is
below 10 seconds so this is uh if you
want to win this with black you have to
go into
all all-out pre-move mode so volleyball
continues king d3 he wants to get his
king over
try and gobble up these pawns and just
win and here uh we have kinked the d6 by
hodge king d5 is a little bit stronger
as it prevents
king e4 but okay king d6 it's still
completely winning for black
king e4 we have king to c5 now a bit of
a
you know going up the hill here king of
five and now king to d4 we have king to
g6
and now e4 now hatch just starts pushing
his pass pawn
we have king captures on g7 but now e3
voyage captures on h6 we have e2
and now king to g6 we have e1 queen
and now uh hatch brings the queen into
the game and the voyboy also starts
pushing his pass pawn
so queen to e7 and here voigway played
h7
and uh it was in this position that uh
the mighty hutch lost
the game on time as it was in this
position that his
clock ran out and voy boy wins the game
and he also wins uh the the park champs
championship
so uh there's uh well uh there's a
lesson to be learned
here of course always played the best
moves uh however if you have to
spend too much time on finding the best
moves maybe it's not always
the best way to go but you know you know
as they say it's always better to lose
on time than
by playing a bad move and here uh it was
a it was a
you know uh it could have been anyone's
game because uh in that position where
voyboy uh could have gone for that uh uh
brilliant queen to e4 move here after
hajj played knight to the e7 queen the
e4 just wins the game on the spot for
boy boy but after missing this it was uh
it was uh
definitely uh all hutch however that boy
but was faster
he ended the game i i believe he still
had like 30 seconds on the clock so he
was
much faster in moving and he won the
game
and yeah always always be mindful of
your clock
because it's not you know a lot of
people say okay
i lost on time my opponent flagged me
yes but you spent
way too much time uh trying to find the
best moves and your opponent was able to
find
decent moves in you know less time and
yeah that also
is taken into account and since this is
a uh you know without a game without an
increment
it does uh you know it does uh makes
sense to make your moves a little bit
faster so this is what happens here
of course black is still completely
winning with queen f8 you block the
queening square also guard your f6 pawn
you can just bring the king in
uh gobble up this pawn and this is
winning however you want to play it
however uh if you don't have any more
time to play then of course
you can't win so yeah uh voyboy wins the
game
game three and uh which was very
impressive as he lost game one by
blundering the queen he bonds back
really nicely in game two and then one
game three on time
so definitely deserving of the win and
here is uh
here is the the brackets uh championship
bracket and also the consolation bracket
from uh from chess.com
so you can see who defeated who who went
into the
semi-finals went into the finals and
yeah charlie uh also known as moist
critical uh he won
uh the consolation championship uh which
is for those who
who were you know kicked out of the main
event
so uh that's uh the game i hope you
enjoyed it and that you've enjoyed this
short coverage
of the pop champs we are continuing
today the chessable master
starts today uh so we are going to enjoy
some some top level chess
again and uh well yeah we'll just take
it from there
so i i do hope you enjoyed it once again
i would like to thank uh benalachi
benzara tajar uh michael valjean uh
simonas plunge
alexandre pereira and robert kretschmar
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing uh
the coverage of the morphe saga checking
up on your one
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world like we said
the chessable masters
start today so thank you and i will see
you soon